[Music]
my pants
[Laughter]
[Music]
big house what's good
how old are they yeah not bad you
brought your a game cools bro i'm always
ready
you're not a sore loser are you not
cause you're about to lose bro i'm gonna
win bro
we'll be tanya let's go boom
oops and a bait rod's heart you're not
winning this look at that beautiful
thing
the cherry's not even in the middle
you're trying to tell me it's beautiful
it's not yeah but everyone knows what
you do with your chest
pick it out and you chuck it in the bed
does anyone else eat the cherry i always
take the cherry off
what yeah you're trying to defend this
snack you take the cherry yeah but it
tastes better oh yeah
i'll take off the first four layers it's
not the same bro
instant when moisture's gone through my
mouth look just crumb
crumbs children come on bob you need
more than water bro
that is the diet so nice and flavors
popping through
beautiful if your nan whacks that out
you know it's going to be a good day i
don't want mine
no i'm all right um yeah i just want to
see what this uh i'll just how do you
pronounce it
[Laughter]
which one are we going for right so the
little pyramid yeah is cashew
okay and the other one your one's got
pistachio and
cranberry in it i think but wait okay
there's a way to eat buck lover
you eat it upside down okay why
because the flavors hit your palate
number one the flavor hits your palette
and number two like a bakewell
the top layer is very dry okay so if we
went in now and put this in our mouths
our mouths will dry out so you go
seriously so i should have done that
with the the bakewell no you should just
put the bake right in the bin bro
all right so look right okay syrup slide
up so you've got a nice like
syrupy glossy delicious bit okay
and i'm not going to put this all in my
mouth i'm going to go apply it yeah
you feel that it's moisture okay it's
good
i'm going to give it has i'm going to
give it a house i'm holding my hands
okay there was no other there was never
going to be any other answer
one nil sick
right so um
lemonade in a beautiful bottle not in a
can
there's a little bit more money spent in
this and you've got vinto
need i say any marmot this is purple yes
and it just tastes it's just like an
absolute party one thing that's purple
that's good for you besides an aubergine
grapes
[ __ ] there wasn't a single grape in the
street and [ __ ]
all right all right so let's go let's go
with him toe first yeah we're gonna go
inside yeah
listen listen they all do that
every can drink yeah and how satisfying
is it
bipto beautiful so look
this is just a very good lemonade in a
glass bottle someone spent a little bit
more money than a purple cat
flat [ __ ] off that is flat no it's not
that is flat it's not flat your one
might be flat
that is flat just listen yeah what what
imagine listen
vimto is great because it's a [ __ ] drink
that we enjoy in a [ __ ] country with
[ __ ] weather yeah yeah
[ __ ] that off you're abroad you're on
holiday you're eating like
we're not we're in london yeah but i'm
the blood in me
is abroad yeah so we're abroad we're
eating grilled fish
there's a lovely little onion and sumac
salad and someone brings you
a [ __ ] beautiful lemonade that's not
that's not doing anything i i totally
agree with you if we were on holiday
we're in london vinto close your eyes
and drink of into where are you
macclesfield summer state
ah
[Laughter]
it says legendary on the bottle this
just says vimto
fizzy i mean this is selfish
legendary 1930 from the mountain i'm
sorry i'm not letting you have this one
i'll let you have the first one you know
what we're not going to be able to agree
on this because vinto is [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's not it's it's dead it's not
like it's delight i don't even want to
try this because i know
i've had some bad um experiences with
turkish july
um anything rose water [ __ ]
[ __ ] man exciting uh
two types three types of turkish delight
including me
um should we go uk first yeah
the uk got the chocolate on yeah yes
they have which makes
i thought you might give it a little bit
of head start though i don't know
chocolate on it oh man it doesn't even
feel nice
oh look at that
you can just peel the chocolate off i'm
just trying to delete me it's like
eating potpourri
or like a scented candle imagine you bit
into a rose candle with chocolate on it
that's what you've got kiwis then anyone
over the age of 75.
oh they're ranked no so traditionally
it's like you just put this in your
mouth like you normally do anywhere else
in the world
um are you gonna go full bit are we
gonna buy it
again it's like i could eat that it's
like in your landscape
that's nicer than that it's probably
because this is traditional
yeah and this has to have some sort of
artificial
in order to keep it structured
[Music]
not gonna lie i love marmite you know uh
so this is pecmez
this is a great molasses okay um and if
i don't know if any of you have seen
us a certain type of turkish bread
that's circular covered in sesame seeds
you know
it's dipped into this it's like a big
bagel we'll stick it into that and then
dip in
sesame seeds and then baked aha yes
all right cool sick sick
all right um you described it this is a
tough one this is a tough one
traditionally i've never eaten these two
things together okay for me this is a
this is a main component to that right
so before these are cooked they're
dipped in that and then dipped in sesame
seeds and you get that sweetness
through that so you wouldn't normally
get that and drizzle i wouldn't but for
the sake of research and development
yeah
let's give it a little dribble
syrup so just dive straight in yeah i'm
going to break mine apart
okay so what's it what's it taste like
is it like a little bit soy
oh it's more bitter than it is sweet but
when you bake with it
you allow that sweetness to come out
whereas if you eat it like that
you need something clean yeah to go
against it so like whether it's
yeah yeah bread's good though this bread
is nice yeah the bread is nice turkish
bagel's name
marmite i'm totally tell me about
marmite sam i actually don't know
a lot about it i just know that my mum
loves it where are we going
i want a little bit more mama i'm not
gonna lie you know i've got quite a bit
on
wait you put both together lucky
sandwich all it needs a bit gravy
let me agree with it you ready
mama you know so wait this goes against
everything i believe
in right if we're talking simmet over
marmite sandwich i'm picking simmet
but if we're talking about pet mez and
pecmez alone i'm getting marmite
so marmite right so i can announce
the winner is turkey
[Music]
thank you thanks thanks i'm also half
english so i'm
upset yeah you're feeling my pain yeah
yeah i'm upset i'm actually
seriously guys if we want to win are you
really going to bring bombay mix
we might as well just say we've lost it
we might we might
at least get some waters guys come on
walker's original i don't even want to
taste this one after i have this in
front of me
no no